To understand how the multi-level
page table saves space,
let's look at an example of a simple and
small two-level page table.
In this example,
we will use a very small virtual address
where we have an offset and the page
number, and each of these is 4 bits.
So using a flat page table,
we would need 2 to the 4th entries in
it, one for each possible page number.
So the entries would be
numbered 0 through 15.
And we would index with our page
number here, and get our frame number.
With the two-level page table,
let's say we split this 4-bit page
number into two 2-bit pieces.
So the same virtual address
still has a 4-bit page number
that we split into two, 2-bit pieces.
The outer part of the page number
is used to index into a four-entry
outer page table, and
each entry in this outer page table can
point to a four-entry inner page table.
So in total,
we have fourinner page tables.
Once we find the pointer to
the correct one, we can use
the inner part of the page number
to tell us which entry to use and
that gives us our frame number.
So as indicated previously, the total
size of all the inner page tables
here is the same as the original
size of the flat page table here.
We had 16 entries here,
we have 4 times 4 entries here,
plus we added the space for
the outer page table.
So where are the savings?
The savings are in that if there is an
unused large part of the address space,
such that all of these entries do
not correspond to physical memory,
then we don't need this and
we can mark here in the outer page table
that the entry's not necessary, and then
we can eliminate this inner page table.
In a larger address space the outer
page table will have many pointers,
most of which will point to inner page
tables like this, so we eliminate them.
So we end up having one reasonably
large outer page table, but
one that we can fit in memory.
And a small number of inner page tables,
each of which is reasonably sized,
and fits in memory.
But we don't have most of the inner
page tables, so we save a lot of space.